a Tasmanian devil is carnivorous
marsupial in fact is the largest living
carnivorous marsupial in the world is
the top predator of Tasmania and as a
specialized scavenger also has a
recycling job which is to clear all the
dead animals that are in the landscape
so it has a very important ecological
role in keeping the ecosystem in a good
balance the spine intervals are solitary
strictly speaking there on living in
groups or in family groups but despite
that they're quite social why social but
they're not that friendly to each other
so they can be quite aggressive when
having disputes over meat for example of
a food so yeah growling and biting is
part of a normal to spending Devil's
life the Tasmanian devils affected by a
very horrible disease called devil
facial tumour disease and this disease
is characterized by large cancerous
lesions that form around the face and
the neck of the affected Devils the
disease kills the devil's very quickly
and it's thought to have a hundred
percent mortality so it's had a
devastating effect on the population
devil facial tumour disease is a very
strange and bizarre new type of cancer
which is arisen recently and it has many
devil population is actually a cancer
which is transmissible so it can be
spread between devils these tumors were
first seen by a wildlife photographer in
the far northeast of Tasmania in 1996
the disease turned up at my long-term
study site on the frozen a peninsula on
the east coast of Tasmania in 2001
within 12 months of seeing the disease
at my study site I realized that it was
both spreading and it was causing major
population decline